right so here's our first example we're
gonna try and prove the ^ n is greater
than N squared and then you've got all
this stuff over here which I know it
looks really complicated but don't freak
out the only reason why I've written all
these symbols is because I'm lazy I
don't want to write all the words out
and we have symbols for this if you've
never encountered this before let me
give you a really brief explanation n is
the number that we're interested in and
this is the Greek letter epsilon there
it's technical meaning is is an element
of I n is an element of this set here
the Z is for a German words R which is
basically about integers whole numbers
counting numbers and so when you say
ends an element of this set what you're
basically saying is what kind of number
is n n is one of the integers but we
continue going and we say it's not just
any of the integers this sum it's
vertical line it means such that so I
read this as and isn't integer such that
it's one of those integers where it's
bigger than four okay so those are the
conditions on n that I set in the
question so what we're gonna do is we're
going to work through our normal three
steps when it comes to every induction
proof we're going to test test the base
case we're going to assume that this
thing is true for some arbitrary value
then we're going to do the main part of
the work which is the proof step okay so
let's make sure we start at the top
because even from step one there are a
few differences between this kind of
induction proof and your series of
sequences or your divisibility proofs
okay so for starters have a look n is
greater than four but ends in integer so
my base case is not going to be four
it's going to be five so I'm going to
test for it equals five now before I
write down the next step let me tell you
how not to write the next step please do
not write two to the power of 5 is
greater than 5 squared even though it is
true that to the power of 5 is greater
than 5 squared here's why this is what
you're trying to prove or you're trying
to show by going through this test that
the statement is actually true for your
base case right
now if you say this right from the
outset then you kind of assumed that we
are going to get two assumptions but
that's later on this is not something
you're supposed to be assuming this is
something you're supposed to be testing
and of course you don't always get
something nice and simple like to the
power of five which you know the value
of or five squared which you know the
value of sometimes you've got to get
something much more complicated on both
sides you don't know that the left-hand
side is greater than the right-hand side
until you get all the way to the end
through there working so you cannot
begin this way you're supposed to end
that way so what do you write instead
well we've eat equalities I recommend
that you take the left hand side wrong
color and the right hand side separately
so here's what we do we have the left
hand side and we say what's that equal
to well it's two to the power of five
don't skip any steps actually do the
substitution and then evaluate once you
don't left on the left I'm gonna do the
right on the right that's going to give
me in this case N squared that's five
squared so that's 25 left over here
right over there I can say oh well in
this case the left hand side is greater
than the right hand side at least it is
for this N equals five values so there
we go it's true base case is done next
we move on to the assumptions so I'm
going to assume that this is true for N
equals K now I'm going to go ahead and
write this and usually people just say
that right assume that that's true or
even to say use those words assume true
for N equals K and then they write this
and most people are pretty happy to pack
up the shop and leave but I want to
emphasize to you just like in
specifically exactly like n K is not
just any number there are conditions on
K care has to be a certain kind of
number namely the same kind of number
that n is now we usually skip over stuff
like this but I'm going to make a big
song and dance about it because here's
all the same conditions if you leave out
this step you literally missing the
crucial piece to actually do the
induction so you must state this just
like when you're solving functions and
you have a domain restriction the domain
really matters it's tempting to leave it
off but without this I promise you by
the end we will not be able to solve
this so I've written it down tests
assume now I have to write down the
proof step so that is for N equals k
plus 1 what does it look like so up here
I'm going to write it as 2 to the k plus
1 is greater than k plus 1 all squared
ok so here's what I'm trying to prove
now at this point is where I choose
between one of my two methods and you
really cared for pretty much any
induction inequality proof you pretty
much can choose either of these usually
what is better but in this case I'm
going to stick with method two you might
ask how did I know that it's method 2
once we get to the end of this I'll try
and explain why I think this is more
useful so what I need to do is to get
here is the K + 1 statement I want to
try and get it in the form F of K all
the stuff to do with K on one side and
then 0 on the other side in this case
it's not that complicated
all I need to do is subtract this K + 1
all squared then I'm gonna 0 on the
right hand side ok so I've got it in the
form a function of K see all that
there's my function of K put all the kz
you'll get a number out it's greater
than zero and now what I'm going to do
is start with this thing on the left
hand side this is the object that I want
to consider in fact I'm even going to
write it in that way I'm gonna say
consider the left hand side which equals
2 to the k plus 1 minus K plus 1 or
squared ok so I've got to do two things
here number one I want to twist and turn
this into such a form that I can use the
assumption I haven't said anything about
the assumption yet in my proof I've just
got my first line so I want to work this
in a way or manipulate it so that I can
see the terms that you can see here okay
so for instance I noticed that on the
left hand side of my assumption I have a
to the power of K that's the exactly
because I have a to the power of K in
this statement here I just need to kind
of massage it a little bit so it's a
little more obvious so you can see if I
take out a factor of 2
that gives me to decay in there that's
the thing that I can work with minus k
plus one or squared okay now at this
point I'm going to do something again
that looks a little bit weird because
you're so used to dealing with equations
I'm back to something that you can only
do with inequalities so this will feel
unfamiliar let's just suppose I say
something really boring like a hundred
equals two times 50 okay now if I say
that this is true that's nice
I could sort of you know evaluate this
or write it in different ways but I'm
actually interested in two in this
equation can I use this equation to make
a statement that's it in equality okay
because you can see here I've got
equations here where I want to end up is
here which is in inequality right so for
instance what I could do is see is 50 if
I changed it and substitute it for
something smaller like say 49 okay and
everything else is still the same this
is not equal anymore it's not an
equation anymore but I can say if I
think about this number in this number
because I've swapped the 50 for
something smaller this side over here is
as a whole it's now smaller right
so in comparison see the original thing
which hasn't changed this thing's gotten
smaller this they stay the same
so this is greater than this right you
make this side smaller than the original
theme will be greater than your new
smaller result okay so you can turn an
equation into an inequality using this
fat and we're gonna do exactly the same
thing here watch